indeed the world number two showing why
he is such a boss winning on demand fabi
at one point in this tournament you were
at minus one and honestly there was dirt
being
put on on the coffin
now somehow you have just surged back
into a type of first could you have
imagined this scenario just four rounds
ago
no i was uh not thinking about being in
first place or playing for the for first
place
after i lost two games in a row but
before today's game i was optimistic
because it felt like the trend was kind
of
improving in my tournament
um
i mean i i really thought that this is
maybe not a must-win but pretty close to
a must-win game
uh because okay i mean counting on
tomorrow my fate isn't in my hands even
if i win tomorrow and draw this game
um
and that's why i played the kings indian
but it was a crazy game i
i didn't expect it to go this way it was
and
maybe at some point i was sure i was
losing
um
at some point i was sure i was winning
too like much earlier on then i thought
i'd mess it up and i was like very close
to losing
um and then after the time control i
thought i'm for sure winning but it was
still super difficult to keep it under
control yeah we needed the heart
defibrillator for yasser this one me too
let's go to the moment you had when you
played rook takes on c3 if you can bring
that up yesterday please rook c3 you
seem to pause at this point it's the
point where we were thinking fabi's just
gonna sack why did you hesitate at all
here did i think for so it wasn't that
long but we just thought you'd be just
eager to imbalance the position of work
c3 well i think is rook c3 is looks like
a no-brainer but he did play knight f3
the movie four he invited me to do this
and he had other moves like queen b3 or
something i thought that was his first
intention
because it looks really annoying the
point is 96 is the red not queen b7 but
knight e6
and so i have to stop at queen e7 and
it's a pawn sack like he takes on b7 i
play knight c5 i get the two bishops
i was pretty happy about this outcome
because i really have tremendous
compensation
but i mean i didn't expect him to allow
the
exchange lag so that's why i thought i
mean
he's he's allowing it head-on i have to
think about um
you know what he has in mind because
obviously he he considered it
so at least i in any way it's useful
because i'm going i'm going to use the
calculation that i do here later on
um and i thought his moves were forced
queen c2 and id2
i wasn't sure about my moves but i i
thought
i mean i have so many options i should
kind of keep keep the pace of it because
he was playing quite quickly
and so then you played b5 and all heck
broke loose right here when you play
knight to d3 queen b1 not being the best
defense
yeah right here you must have just
thought okay i'm rocking and rolling
yeah well when i played knight d3 i had
this this knight before in mind
um
he has other moves but queen b1 uh
is a very logical one
because he doesn't care about f2 he just
wants to take on b5 and all my pieces
will be hanging
and i before i was happy with and i
thought cb4 knight f2 like i'm not sure
if i'm
much better or winning but i don't see a
move for him so
at least it's pleasant to give yeah this
is mate bishop d4
um
like he the problem is that like once my
queen gets to the diagonal it's just a
mating attack
um after i'd get rid of his bishop
and then he quickly played rook a5 i
thought this can't be good
uh queen c3 and i expected knight f3
which i thought can't be good but it's
still a lot to calculate with limited
time and then he played bishop b3 and i
thought like everything must be winning
but
but i got very confused and i ended up
going for something which
was certainly not winning yeah bishop
takes g3 was the best move according to
the engine
yeah i think i thought if he gets like
rook a3 mike why would i just go to e5
um
yeah this was probably very simple and i
i should have
not you know
not overthought it and just
played a simple move but i really
thought bishop v4 might just be winning
on the spot because of f4
and then after g4 i didn't see anything
right now he was suddenly back in the
struggle yeah and then i i was also
getting low on time so i
i thought yeah
like after
queen g1 which i missed i was suddenly
worried that i'm like almost losing
um which i see the bar now it says it's
not the case
but but you know it's it's a bit scary
because knight f3
um
i mean i'm also getting under attack and
i i don't have like an obvious next move
so i was happy to find this king of fade
h6 because
h6 was really important i need to stop
my g5
um
hear the engine after 8 16 g5
yeah i i wasn't uh well the move i was
happy with was a mistake
[Laughter]
to start with i thought h5 is not like a
bat
out yeah now my king gets under
now your king is trapped i think yeah
maybe rook b7 now because suddenly
uh my king can't escape like it could in
the game with king of six
but uh i think we were both a bit too
short on time to figure out the position
right exactly now that's just super
sharp
and then you got to
it was clear at his time control that
there was a problem because he just
started
you could sense he was very nervous and
he played defensively at this point
instead of being as aggressive as he
could although he was putting up a very
heroic defense at some point and he why
did you play rookie five in our rookie
three i thought he'll expect rookie
three
ah i wasn't sure which was better
um but rookie five looked like
things i threatened to take but it's not
really clear if i'm always going to
threaten to take like after rook v8 and
here i'm going to try to take with check
or queen c3 and
queen of three so i thought
it was more important to have that
queen um
the queen threatening f3 rather than the
rook but i don't know i i mean
um
for sure we were making mistakes
right yeah rookie three was stupid
because i i should have played knight d3
and then we get the game which is
probably winning for black yes
we were very surprised you didn't play
were you worried he might guess the move
knight d3 at this point
that wasn't it it's just that after
rookie three rook i thought maybe
i wasn't sure if knight d3 rooker phone
rookie three was was really very good
for black it's only after time control
that i realized he has almost no moves
so
so i thought maybe after work up when
there was like rook takes f3 which
doesn't quite work out
um and queen d5
i think that one uh
he has this um
queen g2 move maybe four is also a draw
uh queen g well queen g2 might just be
winning so that's a bit of an issue
[Laughter]
nicely put
british understatement no maybe not
maybe knight d3 maybe i keep it together
but uh but anyway this is not what i i
want right exactly
and it was only after time control did
he finally make the fun the blunder
which was yeah he played this so quickly
but i the queen is bad on g2 because it
runs into 91.
i think he was thinking that after like
queen c3 he could move his bishop
somewhere bishop before but then he has
no squares for his bishop because rook
h3
and queen's three knight have two wins
um which is maybe not even necessary but
i think that was the only explanation i
had
for why he played it so quickly i think
we thought the rook b3 was his last best
chance of being able to defend the
position yeah it might not be
um so clear-cut maybe white can hold it
but it's not a fun i mean rugby three is
a really tough move it's not really
tough to find queens and after queen c3
now you were completely in the driver's
seat and dominated it's like after
i mean there was so much to calculate
yeah 95 and an h4 like i couldn't yeah
h4 i wasn't
h4 here yeah the thing is i thought
knight g4 right rook f4 king g8 would
win
um
wow and it's important rook of fate take
queen e6 king james king is covered
but then i realized um
yeah this wins for black he has no more
checks
but then i realize after knight g4 he
can take
rookie one
oh sorry uh after knight g4 no rook f4
king g8 take on g4 yeah rookie g4
rookie one and uh bishop f4 loses
because of queen f3 this is actually
quite important
um
but he had just has queen g1 and
surprisingly his pieces are loose but i
don't
have a way to use them
um
take take and his work on g4 my king is
is again animating that i mean not not
yet now but potentially
so i thought this is maybe just not
better for not so easy at all or yeah
definitely not easy so i wasn't going to
play that i was going to play h4
um
h4 f3
hg king g8
this is like my backup
but he plays bishop h3
now i take on g5
and uh my opponent f3 is kind of
blocking my attack a bit i mean he's
still probably in bad shape
but it's not
uh
not an easy one not i mean this was a
good chance for him
so 95 was was a serious mistake i guess
all right but he didn't find those
defenses he allowed you yeah this wasn't
just sorry all in the position
and you eventually got everything you
possibly want
and this final retreating move with the
queen
uh one one little point here rook brook
e8 was also playable
is there a defense to that
uh yeah i haven't seen it
that's the defense
i didn't see it okay i'll pat myself on
the back for fighting a move uh every
once in a while a blind squirrel friday
night
i i saw this queen c8 and the line would
um which happened in the game and uh
and it was enough to say
don't need more than one win in chess
one win per game
per game is all you get yeah you tried
to find all the wins in in the final
position then you'd you'd be there all
day you know i think that's important
all moves are winning
well
you are tied for first
i don't think you could say that since
round two
one right
around
probably round four
round four yeah there was a point where
before you lost when i was plus one i
think it was no no one was plus two
or maybe round four you were not in
france
because i know because i know because
ray robson wasn't clear first okay in
round four so it must have been by round
three that you were not
i i three i drew all my all my games at
the start and then i
oh you oh i won my third one
my third you're right you know what yeah
don't try to
test the commentary
we follow you just make all the good
moves but you were you were a typhoon
first at one point and then ray did his
thing and then you slipped out now
suddenly you find yourself in the last
round you've got white against
sam against sam who just won his game
all out
i mean
not all out when you're in the lead you
don't necessarily have to go all out
also sam
is not a player who that strategy will
necessarily work against
um
but
i mean i will try of course
all right well well done to get to this
point uh i'll remind you that i picked
you to win the tournament so if that
helps
i already picked carissa to win
thank you guys say say say yeah say go
ahead thank goodness
our life has gone
dramatically you're right they're not
they're
down
happy but they're so far right so the
trend is your way
good luck in your last game thank you
good luck happy